have been sexually mutilated in that way.
In some countries, it's more than 98 percent
of the women are cut that way before they reach maturity.
This is a horrible affliction
on all women that live in those countries.
Another very serious thing is honor killings,
where a family with misinterpretation, again, of a holy scripture --
there's nothing in the Quran that mandates this --
will execute a girl in their family
if she is raped
or if she marries a man that her father does not approve,
or sometimes even if she wears inappropriate clothing.
And this is done by members of her own family,
so the family becomes murderers
when the girl brings so-called disgrace to the family.
An analysis was done in Egypt not so long ago by the United Nations
and it showed that 75 percent of these murders of a girl
are perpetrated by the father, the uncle or the brother,
but 25 percent of the murders are conducted by women.
Another problem that we have in the world
that relates to women particularly is slavery,
or human trafficking it's called nowadays.
There were about 12.5 million people sold from Africa into slavery
in the New World back in the 19th century and the 18th century.
There are 30 million people now living in slavery.
The United States Department of State now has a mandate from Congress
to give a report every year,
and the State Department reports that 800,000 people are sold
across international borders every year into slavery,
and that 80 percent of those sold are women,
into sexual slavery.
In the United States right this moment,
60,000 people are living in human bondage, or slavery.
Atlanta, Georgia, where the Carter Center is located
and where I teach at Emory University,
they have between 200 and 300 women, people sold into slavery every month.
It's the number one place in the nation because of that.
Atlanta has the busiest airport in the world,
and they also have a lot of passengers that come from the Southern Hemisphere.
If a brothel owner
wants to buy a girl that has brown or black skin,
they can do it for 1,000 dollars.
A white-skinned girl brings several times more than that,
and the average brothel owner in Atlanta and in the United States now
can earn about $35,000 per slave.
The sex trade in Atlanta, Georgia, exceeds the total drug trade in Atlanta, Georgia.
So this is another very serious problem, and the basic problem is prostitution,
because there's not a whorehouse in America
that's not known by the local officials,
the local policemen, or the chief of police or the mayor and so forth.
And this leads to one of the worst problems,
and that is that women are bought increasingly and put into sexual slavery
in all countries in the world.
Sweden has got a good approach to it.
About 15 to 20 years ago, Sweden decided to change the law,
and women are no longer prosecuted
if they are in sexual slavery,
but the brothel owners and the pimps and the male customers are prosecuted,
and -- (Applause) -- prostitution has gone down.
In the United States, we take just the opposite position.
For every male arrested for illegal sex trade,
25 women are arrested in the United States of America.
Canada, Ireland, I've already said Sweden,
France, and other countries are moving now towards this so-called Swedish model.
That's another thing that can be done.
We have two great institutions in this country that all of us admire:
our military and our great university system.
In the military, they are now analyzing how many sexual assaults take place.
The last report I got, there were 26,000 sexual assaults
that took place in the military --
26,000.
Only 3,000, not much more than 1 percent, are actually prosecuted,
and the reason is that the commanding officer of any organization --
a ship like my submarine, or a battalion in the Army
or a company in the Marines --
the commanding officer has the right under law to decide
whether to prosecute a rapist or not,
and of course, the last thing they want is for anybody to know
that under their command, sexual assaults are taking place,
so they do not do it.
That law needs to be changed.
About one out of four girls who enter American universities
will be sexually assaulted before she graduates,
and this is now getting a lot of publicity,
partially because of my book, but other things,
and so 89 universities in America are now condemned
by the Department of Education under Title IX
because the officials of the universities are not taking care of the women
to protect them from sexual assault.
The Department of Justice says that more than half of the rapes
on a college campus take place by serial rapists,
because outside of the university system,
if they rape somebody, they'll be prosecuted,
but when they get on a university campus, they can rape with impunity.
They're not prosecuted.
Those are the kinds of things that go on in our society.
Another thing that's very serious about the abuse of women and girls
is the lack of equal pay for equal work,
as you know. (Applause)
And this is sometimes misinterpreted, but for full-time employment,
a woman in the United States now gets 23 percent less than a man.
When I became president, the difference was 39 percent.
So we've made some progress, partially because I was president
and so forth -- (Applause) (Laughter) --
but in the last 15 years, there's been no progress made,
so it's been just about 23 or 24 percent difference
for the last 15 years.
These are the kind of things that go on.
If you take the Fortune 500 companies,
23 of them have women CEOs,
out of 500,
and those CEOs, I need not tell you,
make less on an average
than the other CEOs.
Well, that's what goes on in our country.
Another problem with the United States
is we are the most warlike nation on Earth.
We have been to war with about 25 different countries
since the Second World War.
Sometimes, we've had soldiers on the ground fighting.
The other times, we've been flying overhead
dropping bombs on people.
Other times, of course, now, we have drones that attack people and so forth.
We've been at war with 25 different countries
or more since the Second World War.
There was four years, I won't say which ones,
where we didn't --
(Applause) -- we didn't drop a bomb, we didn't launch a missile,
we didn't fire a bullet.
But anyway, those kinds of things, the resort to violence
and the misinterpretation of the holy scriptures
are what causes, are the basic causes, of abuse of women and girls.
There's one more basic cause that I need not mention,
and that is that in general, men don't give a damn.
(Applause) That's true.
The average man that might say, I'm against the abuse of women and girls
quietly accepts the privileged position that we occupy,
and this is very similar to what I knew when I was a child,
when separate but equal had existed.
Racial discrimination, legally, had existed for 100 years,
from 1865 at the end of the War Between the States, the Civil War,
all the way up to the 1960s,
when Lyndon Johnson got the bills passed
for equal rights.
But during that time, there were many white people
that didn't think that racial discrimination was okay,
but they stayed quiet,
because they enjoyed the privileges of better jobs,
unique access to jury duty,
better schools, and everything else,
and that's the same thing that exists today,
because the average man really doesn't care.
Even though they say, "I'm against discrimination against girls and women,"
they enjoy a privileged position.
And it's very difficult to get the majority of men
who control the university system,
the majority of men that control the military system,
the majority of men that control the governments of the world,
and the majority of men that control the great religions.
So what is the basic thing that we need to do today?
I would say the best thing that we could do today
is for the women in the powerful nations
like this one, and where you come from,
Europe and so forth, who have influence and who have freedom to speak and to act,
need to take the responsibility on yourselves
to be more forceful in demanding
an end to racial discrimination against girls and women
all over the world.
The average woman in Egypt
doesn't have much to say about her daughters
getting genitally mutilated and so forth.
I didn't even go down to detail about that.
But I hope that out of this conference,
that every woman here will get your husbands to realize
that these abuses on the college campuses and the military and so forth
and in the future job market,
need to protect your daughters and your granddaughters.
I have 12 grandchildren, four children, and 10 great-grandchildren,
and I think often about them
and about the plight that they will face in America,
not only if they lived in Egypt or a foreign country,
in having equal rights,
and I hope that all of you will join me
in being a champion for women and girls around the world
and protect their human rights.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)